okay wait okay you would go there were
lots of music as it were wait wait wait
oh you're gonna be told and after the
kids have done a lip-sync for their life
and one girl lip syncs better than the
other to save herself and the other girl
has to sashay away and that's when I
tell one of the the loser
I'm not loser the one who did not win
but tell that girl to sashay away
I so happen should I serve a little bit
of sauces like well no there's a lot of
tension at this point because they're
waiting you you will have just lip-synch
for your life
okay and you're waiting for the verdict
okay right so you sort of praying inside
okay that you get to stay okay okay this
is the lip yeah yeah yeah nice yeah
that's quite a meaty tuck bye
[Applause]
Jackie my dear I'm sorry but this is not
your time now sashay away
[Applause]
[Music]
well done Jackie balls
[Applause]
[Music]